rapport au vitriol la commission d'
enquête sénatoriale sur l' influence des
cabinets de conseil privé sur les
politiques publiques a rendu ses
conclusions aujourd'hui quatre mois de
travaux et la dénonciation je cite d'un
phénomène opaque et tentaculaire nicolas
fleury il s'appelle mckinsey capgemini
ou presse waterhouse coopers les
cabinets de conseil ces firmes souvent
peu connus du grand public n'ont jamais
eu autant d'influencé au plus haut de
l'état au point de peser sur les
décisions politiques
c'est ce que dénonce aujourd'hui une
commission d' enquête du sénat des pans
entiers des politiques publiques sont
déléguées à des consultants qui n'ont
toutefois aucune légitimité démocratique
il s'agit d'une intrusion en profondeur
du secteur privé dans la sphère publique
ces entreprises interviennent sur des
sujets sensibles comme la campagne de
vaccination contre le coc vide en partie
sous traiter à makeen c'est pour 12
millions d'euros au total l'an dernier
l'état a versé plus d'un milliard
d'euros à des cabinets de conseil des
dépenses qui ne cesse d'augmenter et
bien recours y est devenue une réflexe
en fait de la part de celles et ceux qui
nous gouvernent et peu importe l'argent
qu'on y met y compris quand on fait les
commandes et qu'on n'a pas la livraison
de ces commandes car parfois les
prestations n'aboutisse pas comme une
expertise pour préparer la réforme des
retraites réforme abandonné mais le
conseil lui est facturé près d'un
million d'euros dans leur rapport les
sénateurs déplore un manque de
transparence
pour lutter contre l'opacité il nous
semble utile que d'abord tous les
livrables ce qu'on appelle les livrables
dans les documents fournis par les
cabinets de conseil ne soit sous leur
logo parce qu'ils le sont souvent sous
le logo de l'administration ce qui fait
qu'on ne sait plus qui a fait quoi et
qui assume quoi pendant l' enquête des
sénateurs le gouvernement a réagi avec
une circulaire pour limiter le recours
aux consultants
notre objectif avec tous ces mesures est
donc bien de réduire en 2022 les
dépenses de conseil en stratégie et en
organisation d'au moins 15% par rapport
à 2000 21 15 % de dépenses en moins un
objectif pas assez ambitieux pour les
sénateurs il demande aussi que l'état
rende publique la liste des prestations
de conseil auquel ils recourent
et on débat autour d'eux des rendu des
conclusions pardon j'ai trouvé mon mot
de ce rapport avec eliane assassi
bonsoir soit bienvenue vous êtes
sénatrice communiste de
seine-saint-denis président du groupe
communiste républicain citoyen
écologistes au sénat caroline michel
aguer bonsoir ça grand reporter au
service politique de l'ops hauteur avec
matthieu aron de cette enquête les
infiltrés aux éditions alary jean
sébastien ferjou rebond soit là vous
êtes fondateur-directeur
d'atlantico et leticia costa évidemment
il rester à mes côtés
travail de longue haleine et on le
disait 40 audition 47 personnes
entendues 7300 documents analysés le
tout en quatre mois d'enquêté donc ces
mots qui m'ont frappé phénomène
tentaculaire et opaque
pourquoi je vais commencer par le
tentaculaire pourquoi est ce
tentaculaire sait quelles sont les
politiques publiques concernées un peu
tout oui un brief quand on dit
tentaculaire je pense que ça à prendre
tout son sens parce qu'effectivement il
y à un moment où on ne sait plus qui
fait quoi qui est l'émetteur qui est
celui qui répond à une à une commande je
vous rajoute les sous traitants etc donc
tout ça pas de façon complètement
dispersés on a du mal des voix a
retrouvé en fait d'ossements et les
livrables mais on a du mal à retrouver
voilà qui qui qui est à l'origine et qui
est maître d'oeuvre dans cette danse et
à faire donc c'est vraiment c'est ce qui
nous amène à penser et je les les
pensées immédiatement au début de la la
commission denquête qu' il y avait
effectivement un manque de transparence
évident donc là on vient sur l'opacité
exact exemple ce soit ça m'a frappé dans
dans vos conclusions il ya pas forcément
le logo du cabinet qui travaillent sur
les documents qui sont fournis ça
lorsque pas pu être pris pour un
document ministériel a toujours brève
dans certains cas là c'est pour certains
cas et ça a été le cas notamment durant
la crise sanitaire où nous savons qu'il
est nous avons le document qui existe et
nous savons qu'il a été réalisée par
mckinsey mais effectivement son logo
n'apparaît pas sur ceux sur ce document
oro s'aperçoit que le même document avec
des chiffres et des des graphismes
différents a été produit par mckinsey en
australie c'est à dire que y compris il
faut des copier coller
de documents qu'ils remettent à des adp
à d'autres pays que que la france et ils
cachent en fait le levage et ce coup je
suis pas sûr que ce soit moins cher mais
ce qu'est ce qu'est ce qui est plus
grave c'est que ces documents qui sont
simplement estampillés du logo du
ministère
parts et sa douce avoue son parti puisse
d'exactement au conseil de défense moi
je suis parlementaire je ne sais pas ce
qui se passe au conseil de défense je ne
sais pas qui est membre de ce conseil de
défense donc ça renforce aussi le sujet
de l'opacité du manque de transparence
caroline michel aguer ou le sous titre
de votre livre ses enquêtes sur
l'emprise des cabinets de conseil sur un
état consentants et vous décrivez la
montée en puissance du phénomène on est
quoi au début des années 2000 s'est dit
à quoi la numérisation tout simplement
ça et c'est le la porte d'entrée en
quelque sorte non l'accélération est
vraiment lié au départ c'est un choix
politique c'est un choix absolument
politique et ça ça renforce notre notre
stupéfaction d'avoir réalisé que tout ça
s'est fait sans être votée sans être
présenté dans un plein déni démocratique
au départ donc on est au milieu des
années 2000 c'est nicolas sarkozy qui
arrive au pouvoir avec la rgpp la
révision générale des politiques
publiques dont on a retenu à l'époque
parce que c'était la mesure on a plus
visible le non remplacement d'un
fonctionnaire sur deux partant à la
retraite en vérité ce qui s'est joué à
cette époque là c'est un grand plan de
réduction des coûts qui a été confiée
aux consultants est tué une volonté
d'appliquer des méthodes complètement
différente
à la fonction publique des méthodes
importées par les consultants par des
multinationales du conseil parce que des
consultants il y en a toujours eu en
france quittaient plus techniques plus
précises sur des compétences on les
appelait les les consultants ingénieurs
ce qui arrive au milieu des années 2000
c'est tout à fait autre chose c'est les
grandes multinationales qui sont pour la
plupart américaines qui ont cette vision
anglo-saxonne que lemieux d'état c'est
moins d'état qu'il faut réduire les
coûts et qu'ils vont
appliquer des réductions de coûts un peu
à la hache et
terriblement comme ça n'est pas 10 ans
révisé je dirais l'emprise de l'état sur
la société parce qu'après tout si vous
réduisez les coûts mais vous réduisez
les missions pourquoi pas mais là ce qui
est fait c'est la promesse des cabinets
de consultants cette promesse magique du
changement qu'on va va pouvoir faire la
même chose voire mieux avec moi et ça ça
dure depuis 15 ans dans un manque de
transparence totale jean sébastien
ferjou coco comment vous vous recevez ce
rapport est peut-être le principe de
l'utilisation des cabinets de conseils
utilisation grandissante par par les
ministères il ya deux choses là le
principe il ya l'utilisation
grandissante crème deux choses
profondément différente parce que le
principe et vous l'avez dit que vous
pouvez répondre sur les deux aspects
mais sur le premier aspect que l'état
puisse avoir recours ponctuellement à
des cabinets de consultants extérieurs
parce qu'il ya des expertises très
spécifique ça ne me choque absolument
pas en revanche que les cabinets de
conseil se substitue une certaine
manière à l'état sur un certain nombre
de missions le tout dans le psc que vous
décrivez ça c'est choquant mais il faut
se poser la question de pourquoi pas il
ya trois choses qui me frappe dans tout
ce que dans tout ce que vous décrivez
c'est déjà il ya un terrible défaut de
management public l'état ne s'est pas
manager ses troupes aucune entreprise ne
survivrait on aurait survécu pendant
aussi longtemps en tout cas voir des
exemples dans des très grandes
structures d'une efficacité mais ne
survivraient avec des troupes ou des
salariés en incluant des agents de la
fonction publique aussi mal manager
c'est c'est assez ahurissant de voir
parce que les rapports pour le coup
parmi ce que vous mettez en avant dans
ces sur une logistique pour hospitalière
c'est pour imaginer ce que la frontière
pourrait être c'est à dire on est quand
même sur le coeur dur et gagne on n'est
pas sûr tiens il faut inventer une
nouvelle solution de paiement et donc
allons voir un prestataire qui sait
vraiment comment on paye des impôts en
ligne fin je pourrais pas de principe de
l'impôt mais de la solution actuellement
en fm vous dit on faisait appel à des à
des consultants ingénieurs là c'est là
c'est une autre dimension donc voilà
donc il ya le l'incroyable mauvais
management de l'état et rien n'a changé
et c'est à dire qu'on laisse dériver les
choses et pourquoi est-ce qu'on en est
arrivé là c'est là c'est ça la question
intéressante arias la logique que vous
avez décrite mais finalement à des la
surface des choses moi il me semble
qu'il ya aussi autre chose il ya le
rétrécissement du champ du politique en
quelque sorte l'état c'est dévitalisées
est assez dévitalisées parce que d'une
part il ya eu la libéralisation de
beaucoup de choses pas seulement en
france mais dans tous les pays du monde
sauf qu'on n'a pas réformé l'appareil
d'état en france on a fait comme si ça
n'existait pas et on ne l'a pas adapté
c'est comme si vous aviez je sais pas
quoi un constructeur automobile des
maréchal ferrant qui on avait continué à
garder des maréchal ferrant leur causait
des voitures et puis demain des voitures
à batteries électriques et après il ya
la dévitalisation d'appareils d'état
qu'est encore autre chose c'est à dire
que justement sous l'influencé de ce
rétrécissement de l'état qu'est ce qui
s'est passé les ambitieux ils sont
partis ailleurs sûr qu'aujourd'hui les
énarques un type qui est vraiment
ambitieux il est banquier d'affaires il
est à la tête d'un fonds
d'investissement je ne dis pas
individuellement vous ne trouvez pas des
énarques de grande valeur enfin
globalement la compétence elle est parti
ailleurs les raoul boiteux
[Musique]
en termes de cerveau les gens qui ont
créé la sncf qui ont créé edf vous ne
les trouvez plus dans les rangs de
l'état aujourd'hui ça c'est le premier
point un deuxième point des ambitieux
ils sont partis ailleurs et les
audacieux on les a foutu dehors parce
qu'en gros comme une espèce de doxa qui
s'imposaient l'emploi au libéral ou
alors social d'ailleurs libéral fait
bref à partir des années 80 tous les
gens qui pensaient différemment sur
l'europe sur la souveraineté monétaire
sur les questions de souveraineté les
militaires sur les questions de
souveraineté numérique etc on les a
foutu dehors c'était dégage en gros si
vous étiez un peu trop séguiniste ou sur
deux tout autre sujet ce n'est pas
strictement politique si vous déranger
on vous a poussé à la porte et ces gens
là ils sont jamais revenus aux nerfs
normalement oui c'est compliqué quand
même c'est pas aussi partie
si vous voulez je vous présente beaucoup
les gens qui sont dans des cabinets le
conseil juste lier qui sont bien plus
rémunérés mais qui sont pourtant énarque
et inspecteur des finances voulait
dégager pas c'est les pousser à parler
meder c'est une des dimensions
intéressante c'est à dire que c'est laid
les passerelles ou alors le
l'attractivité des cabinets de conseil
privé c'est on va retrouver dans ces
cabinets des hauts fonctionnaires qui
travaillent évidemment sur le même thème
avant qu'ils étaient moins bien payés et
qui est qui font bénéficier leurs
connaissances et ce qu'ils ont appris du
management de l'état et dans la fonction
publique à des à des boîtes privées
c'est tout à fait ça mais la bonne
question il ya plusieurs questions il ya
là là là la question de la de la non
adaptation ce que vous disiez un peu de
notre système en fait public mais c'est
valable pour la fonction publique d'état
comme c'est valable pour l'hospitalière
comme c'est valable pour la territoriale
et donc on en parlait tout à l'heure
mais un problème de rh aussi de
ressources humaines une question de
formation aussi et quand on regarde moi
je suis fonctionnaire d'origine et c'est
vrai que la formation dans la fonction
publique c'est vraiment pilotes
professionnels y en a pratiquement plus
et puis il ya cette fameuse question
effectivement des salaires les salaires
de la fonction publique et alors les
plus faibles étant ceux des
collectivités territoriales
mais on pourrait parler de la fonction
publique hospitalière avec la crise
sanitaire etc etc on aurait il aura pas
de mon point de vue un coup de la région
et de la recherche à coup de primes mais
forcément c'est tentant c'est en tant
que d'être d'abord appelée par un
cabinet privé il ya de la reconnaissance
en fait on nous reconnaît quelque part
et puis à cette question salariale qui
est au coeur de tout ça et le statut de
la fonction publique
en fait je pense serait à revisiter il
est comment dire il n'est plus adapté en
fait à l'évolution oui mais faut lui
résister de par parler d'eux de quoi
c'est à dire toutes les perfections la
formation pour leurs démarches les
personnels qui sont efficaces parce que
c'est le souci de l'efficacité et le
salaire qui
exactement est ce qu'on a besoin d'une
fonction publique de service public et
donc d'argent public dans ce pays moi je
pense profondément que oui oui mais il
faut qu'il soit plus fort et efficace
dont ils ont envie l'a fait on est tout
à fait d'accord je suis tout à fait
d'accord avec vous mais alors comment on
fait parce qu'il ya des mots et puis à
l'exacte donc il faut de changer
complètement de paradigme et on a des
fonctionnaires qui sont en souffrance
totalement on voit bien avec une hausse
qui sont mal gérées
et on le voit particulièrement à
l'hôpital on ne parle jamais de la
fonction publique territoriale et je
pense que les plus grandes souffrances
sont chez les territoriaux qui au bout
des commandes des salaires de misère
mais y compris les fonctions
de maltraitance
est urgent de ma nation ce qu'on vous ne
voyez pas les gens travaillent pas que
pour gagner de l'argent il travaille
aussi pour avoir
mais après il ya quand même le poids de
l'état dans la madeleine l'état est
devenu une gigantesque machine de
clientèle électorale regard des
appareils plus de dix mille
fonctionnaires en plus depuis le début
l'élection de bertrand delanoë et
pourtant même chose on n'a cessé de
délégués toujours plus de missions qui
étaient auparavant assumé par les
fonctionnaires de la ville de paris sa
des entreprises privées
à vous en appel à des contractuels
tu es donc on fait appel à des
contractuels à vous entendre vous
interpeller les uns les autres c'est ce
qui est intéressant c'est aussi l'image
du de la fonction publique l'image des
fonctionnaires et la façon dont les
ministres perçoivent leur fonction
publique est ce que c'est une des
explications du phénomène c'est à dire
qu'ils font pas suffisamment confiance à
leurs fonctionnaires et donc se tourner
vers des caisses c'est exactement ça
c'est une des choses qu'on a découverte
quand on a fait le livre avec matthieu
aron moi il y avait quelque chose qui me
tracassait beaucoup au début c'était
pourquoi parce qu'on voyait bien c'est
ce qu'on peut
a écrit on a parlé de putsch progressif
mais qu'on s'entend parce que ça n'est
pas un coup d'état ou au sens où les
ctom n'aurait pas voulu au contraire
l'état les politiques et les hauts
fonctionnaires eux-mêmes ont ouvert
grand des portes et on a passé beaucoup
de temps à essayer de comprendre il ya
d'abord deux choses assez ferme de temps
il ya d'abord des hauts fonctionnaires
qui se sentent dévalorisés au milieu des
années 2000 par rapport aux copains qui
sont partis dans le privé qui sont un
peu dans un phénomène de ringardisation
voilà et qui se disent on va moderniser
tout ça du coup on va devenir on va
peut-être s'ouvrir aussi peut-être des
perspectives de carrière et qui font
appel au cabinet de consultants quelque
part aussi un peu un truc de d'être en
surplomb se disant que ce sont surtout
les fonctionnaires de terrain qui vont
souffrir et pas tellement la haute
fonction publique et après ils
s'enclenche hardeuse même un deuxième
phénomène c'est la mise en place d'un
écosystème c'est pour ça qu'on a parlé
d'infiltration de quelque chose de
beaucoup plus diffus qui est que les
cabinets de conseil ont mis en place que
ce que les sociologues appellent
l'hybridation des élites c'est à dire
qu'il y a les allers-retours les
pantoufles et retrouve le pantouflage
qu'on connaît il ya aussi tout un tas de
clubs comme club des acteurs publics ou
de think tank où ces gens là se
rencontrent et forme finalement un dob
de dogme commun qui ne se fait plus au
sein des partis maintenant les
discussions de fond elles viennent
ddd d'éclat mines et de conseil qui sont
devenus les experts de la chose publique
de la transformation public edouard
philippe quand il fait 4 de cap 2020 2
qui n'appellent il appelle thomas london
de makeen fait pas que il ya d'autres
gens mais je vais dire moscovici ça
aussi on le raconte dans un livre quand
il est nommé à la tête de la cour des
comptes et qui veut se projeter sur 2025
il appelle les grands cabinets de
conseils dernier point ça c'est vraiment
une des révélations qui nous a le plus
s'arrêter les cabinets de conseil sont
devenus prépondérants
sont devenus le pr et inspirateur de
grands diplômes et des diplômés de nos
grandes écoles c'était jeudi rennes 7 %
en 2007 c'est devenu 30% en 2020 les
élèves des grandes écoles qui partent
dans les grands cabinets de conseil ce
qui veut dire que la matière grise elle
l'est dans les cabinets de conseil
aujourd'hui donc aujourd'hui si vous
voulez en gros pas les plus intelligents
parce qu'il ya des énarques extrêmement
brillant qui ont fait beaucoup d'études
qui souffre d'être méprisés dévalorisé
mais en tout cas si vous voulez une
concentration de matière grise et ben
vous atteler mckinsey mais c'est géraud
lambert girl est donc ce phénomène que
vous décrivez si il joue même dans
l'urgence d'ailleurs un ministre qui va
dans l'urgence faire appel à qui a un
cabinet de conseil c'est exactement ce
que olivier véran disait le 16 février
dernier sur france info à propos du
début de la crise covin notre pays était
en guerre 1 1 pendant je verse été les
mots du président était vrai quand vous
devez équipe et un tgv en 48 heures pour
faire de ce tgv normal un tgv qui
travaille va transporter 30 malades en
coma intubé et ventilé du grand-est vers
le sud est de la france vous avez 48
heures pour le faire vous êtes quand
même content de trouver des gens qui se
trouvent qu'ils ont la compétence pour
le faire ils sont un secteur privé ils
sont pas dans les administrations ils
sont pas dans mon bus dans les bureaux
du ministère
ça m'a surtout parce que on a une
sécurité civile qui
gérait les cabinets
le pompier
c'est pour ça qu'on a choisi cet extrait
parce que on est vraiment dans le
réflexe des intellectuels du ministre
d'abord
d'une certaine fébrilité quand même de
la part de gouvernements c'est d'aller
jusqu'à ne pas raconter la vérité pour
ne pas dire autre chose est
de nous de nous dire ce afin de tenir ce
genre de propos de nous de recevoir une
lettre une circulaire du premier
ministre
le jour même où est auditionné la
ministre madame de montchalin d'une
circulaire qui n'est pas contraignante
où il ya pratiquement rien dedans on dit
pour réduire de 15% le recours aux
cabinets privés etc donc je pense que
cette commission denquête mais aussi
votre votre livre pour le moins
l'annnonce du dic ont créé au sein de
l'état major
on va y revenir sur les communications
du gouvernement notamment avec laeticia
je vous donne la parole là dessus parce
que moi je l'analyse aussi comme
la perception que l'administration sait
plus faire pendant dans l'esprit dans du
ministre de la santé il ya plusieurs sur
générale il ya beaucoup beaucoup
d'hypocrisie mais collective collective
parce qu'en france on parle de la
puissance de l'état du service public on
en parle comme des réalités virtuelles
on se pose pas la question de
concrètement à quoi servent les gens
qu'on se pose surtout pas la question de
l'allocation des moyens on peut discuter
dans l'absolu sur le nombre de
fonctionnaires c'est pas la même chose
s'ils font 6 ou s'ils font ça après il
ya beaucoup d'hypocrisie parce qu'on a
faits au regard des moralisation de
l'état il y aura plus 40 membres dans un
cabinet ministériel heures moyennant
quoi pendant le début du quinquennat
macron à ministre avait droit je crois
dix conseillers et un ministre délégué
ou un secrétaire d'état car une fois que
vous avez enlevé son choix la ménagère
son emploi du temps celui qui gère les
relations avec le parlement parce que
c'est utile pour vous défendre un projet
de loi et les relations avec la presse
il vous reste qui pour faire face à
l'administration parce que de deux
choses l'une soit on est dans un sport
système comme on dit à l'américaine vous
changez les directeurs d'administration
centrale vous nommer des gens qui
partagent la même vision politique que
joue à ce moment là vous avez confiance
on n'est pas dans cette configuration là
en france on ne l'a pas fait et même à
crolles avait évoqué il ne pas fait
qu'est ce qui s'est passé vous avez des
miss qui tout simplement non plus les
mêmes compétences regarder le niveau des
ministres aujourd'hui par rapport à ce
qu'ils étaient il ya vingt ans il ya
trente ans il ya je vous parlais de la
dévitalisation de l'état enfin c'est le
cas dans la haute fonction publique mais
c'est le cas dans le personnel politique
aussi vous avez des tas de nice ne
comprennent rien regarder le nombre de
lois non mais c'est pas juste pour le
plaisir de le dire il ya des indicateurs
extrêmement objectif regardez le nombre
de projets de règlements de loi etc qui
sont retoqués par le conseil d'état tout
simplement parce qu'on ne sait plus
écrire la loi correctement c'est vous
dire le niveau où en est l'état donc il
ya une énorme hypocrisie après y'a
l'hypocrisie qu'est la nature même du
maquereau nisme à mon sens dira le
maquereau nice où c'est quoi c'est d'une
certaine r la négation du politique la
négation du clivage c'est la droite la
gauche ça n'existe pas en me dire ce
parti la droite est nul ce parti de la
gauche est nu c'est une chose peut-être
vous pouvez tomber sur un mauvais
dentiste pour retournerai chez un autre
dentiste après le principe c'est pas la
même chose que la réalité est donc là
qu'est ce qui nous dit emmanuel macron
ai dit non il y aurait des espèces de
solutions techniques qui flotterait
finalement comme un gisement de pétrole
et puis quelqu'un d'un peu malin il va
savoir aller le chercher un expert un
sachant et on l'a vu pendant la gestion
de la crise et c'est ça le réflexe
olivier ferrand sais quoi dire la
politique ça n'existe pas acte ça
n'existe pas alors que je suis désolée
la crise du coc vite si vous pouvez la
gérer en dix ans la priorité c'est la
sécurité absolue où la priorité c'est la
préservation des libertés publiques où
la priorité c'est je sais pas la dignité
des personnes ça c'est de la politique
et ça aucun mckinsey au monde où roland
berg heures au monde ne sera capable de
faire ses arbitrages là et je trouve que
l'imposture intellectuelle du maquereau
nice mais les lacets de faire semblant
que durée des solutions un peu magique
avec un peu de bol on sait pas s'ils
allaient trouverai je joue redonne la
parole car il me fait rire parce que
dans votre livre vous citez à propos des
macros à vous citer alain minc qu'est ce
qui dit d' emmanuel macron sur son
physique c'est un président consultant
qu'il est comme eux que c'est leur idole
et qui parle comme eux et qu'ils
s'expriment comme eux et qu'il a les
mêmes idées qui se comprennent et
arenas ya deux mois je suis complètement
d'accord c'est que s'est présenté sous
un angle technique départ pour minimiser
l'influencé l'importance des cabinets de
conseil c'est budgétaire on va on va
faire des choix budgétaires de bonne
rentabilité sur le principe je crois
qu'on est tous à peu près d'accord on
n'a pas envie de balancer l'argent par
les fenêtres mais en vérité tous ces
choix sont politiques tout ça est
éminemment politique décidé de faire
telles coupures dans tel service public
ou de gérer de telles façons ce tout est
politique et là où je suis d'accord sur
l'imposture du maquereau nisme c'est de
minimiser sa en disant non mais c'est
technique pas du tout ces politiques
alors justement comment emmanuel macron
le candidat puisque c'était sa
conférence de presse cet après-midi a
répondu à une question sur les cabinets
de conseil privé la voilà on écoute
je pense que le sénat a fait un travail
utile et important c'est d'ailleurs le
rôle de nos assemblées de pouvoir faire
cela je pense que il est légitime pour
les ministères d'avoir appel à des
cabinets privés simplement il faut que
ce soit fait à chaque fois selon des
règles transparentes des appels d'offres
et des marchés qui sont passés manière
transparente contrôlable par les
inspections ministériel et parlement par
le parlement dans ses compétences et par
la cour des comptes en tant qu elle
sollicitée par le parlement bon dieu il
ya un bravo pour la commission denquête
vous le prenez melliti c'est ce qui est
intéressant c'est que le gouvernement a
communiqué à communiquer dès le mois de
janvier
parce qu'il y avait eu votre livre parce
que parce qu'il y avait la commission
qu'à la maison je pense que d'un côté la
commission denquête le livre qui sort le
17 février est un mois avant jean castex
c'est vrai sort cette circulaire
ministérielle sur sur l'encadrement du
recours au cabinet de conseil et alors
ce qui est vraiment symptomatique c'est
que le matin de la sortie de votre livre
gabriella talent de pompier de service 1
dans la macro ni et sur le plateau de
bfmtv pour tenter de désamorcer la
petite bombe qui était votre livre
enquête écoutez les cabinets de conseil
doit évidemment être sollicités dès lors
que c'est pour des compétences qu'on ne
trouve pas au sein de l'état d'ailleurs
on veut développer aussi une forme de
cabinet de conseil de l'état en interne
qui peut venir en appui aux
administrations allait créer un cabinet
de conseil comme ça c'est le travail de
ma collègue amélie de montchanin pour
qu'on ait un état plus efficace et plus
performants mais je vais vous dire ça
veut dire évidemment qu'on va continuer
à s'appuyer sur des compétences et des
éclairages du privé qui peuvent sur
certains points sur des questions
informatiques numériques par exemple
nous permettre de nous améliorer
d'améliorer non sur l'émission bon c'est
vrai que là vous continuer mais c'est
vrai que quand même aussi la polémique
mckinsey qui était sorti avant cours de
la crise coville qui a forcé le
gouvernement à préparer une réponse il
fallait bien un pouvoir répondre sur ce
sujet c'est assez clair finalement il
accepte cette stratégie ce recours au
cabinet de conseil qui est donc une
stratégie anglo saxon qui a été
finalement développé sous nicolas
sarkozy et nous disent ok circulez ya
rien à voir il va falloir l'encadré
davantage c'est ce que dit emmanuel
macron finalement les mots n'ont
absolument pas changé la réponse la
réponse défensive n'a pas changé
simplement pour alors on va contrôler on
va on va quand même plus mais maîtrisée
c'est ce recours et surtout on va créer
une task force en avant alors
minutes conseiller voilà on va créer un
cabinet de conseil en interne comme ça
encore plusieurs lacs
peut-être un mois jour peut-être un mot
là-dessus ça si ça ils en ont vous avez
auditionné tellement de personnalités 47
7300 document cette histoire de cabinet
de conseil interne c'est ça existe c'est
un embryon c'est il faut le faire c'est
ce qu'a annoncé gabriela talent mais
pour l'instant on n'en n'a pas
connaissance et je ne suis pas sûr que
ce soit là bas j'ai posé la question la
meilleure des solutions
ça me permet de botter en touche mais le
problème la création d'un cabinet en
interne ne réglera rien à la situation
si on regarde bien le rapport la chose
est tellement énorme et il crée un
besoin en fait il y a un besoin qui a
été créé dans des reer notre
administration ne peut plus s'en passer
aujourd'hui et je je je crains que
effectivement il y a eu toute une petite
musique qui tend à laisser penser
qu'effectivement on ne peut pas se
passer des cabinets conseils que moi je
ne suis pas contre le cabinet un conseil
mais ce dont je le rencontre c'est qu'il
prenne des décisions ils interviennent
dans la décision publique et c'est ça
qui est grave c'est un tueur se situe
elle a dit on n'a pas voté pour les deux
et on n'a pas voté pour mais c'est ça
qui est dangereux mais je voudrais
revenir sur une un autre sujet qui a été
abordé je crois profondément que
l'affaiblissement des politiques de la
politique de l'idée de la politique
l'affaiblissement les corps
intermédiaires au signalement que sont
les associations les syndicats
l'affaiblissement
travail est construit du parlement
appelle ce genre de de recours à des
cabinets à des cabinets privés s'y
rajoutent encore ce que je disais tout à
l'heure le manque de formation des
fonctionnaires
et des trois des trois fonctions des
trois fonctions publiques donc en fait
c'est tout un c'est le cas de le dire
c'est tout un mécano et c'est à dire les
gaules a cette fois ci mais tout un
mécano qui s'est mis en place et qui
illustre effectivement une volonté
politique moi je pense qu'on est au
coeur d'un système
qui tend à
à reprendre cette petite musique selon
laquelle les fonctionnaires sont des
feignants des fonctionnaires ne servent
à rien et donc il faut autre chose que
peut-être plus pernicieux parce qu'il ya
quelque chose qui se développe en
parallèle c'est que dans le même temps
l'état il a fait quoi c'est qu'on a
développé un nombre d' agences
administratives indépendantes parce que
ça va de pair c'est à dire c'est en
suspens procès quoi la logique c'est de
dire les électeurs nous en merde exactes
m donc on va soit déplacé la contrainte
à bruxelles soit en libéralisé donc
aller sur les marchés à l'extérieur et
donc on a plus assumer le débat
politique soit justement ce sont des
autorités administratives indépendantes
ou des cabinets de conseil mais à
l'arrivée c'est le même la même chose le
chant d'une ses nerfs parce qu'en fait
moi je veux bien qu'on ait souri
m'explique de dire arrêtez de dire
qu'elle fonctionnait ok moi j'ai
factuellement est-ce qu'on a un système
d'évaluation qui pour elle et nous
permettre d'en bas mais j'ai dit ce
rapport c'est nous demandons à ce qu'une
évaluation
parce que même l'évaluation de l'action
de l'exécutif par le monde parlement est
tenu dans l'obscurité il n'y en a même
pas de livrables de cabinets conseils
des évaluations ça il ya des rencontres
sont même pas livré il ya des rapports
qui n'a pas livré et que coûte très cher
et donc l'évaluation ça n'existe pas et
donc effectivement c'est une de nos
propositions c'est à dire qu'on évalue
au sein de la fonction publique et des
trois fonctions publiques les
compétences des wings et de ne pas faire
appel à des cabinets privés sont on en a
pas besoin alors je vois là peut-être
pour faire appel oui peut-être dans
certains cas mais passionnant et
passionné mais je reviens quand même sur
la question des cabinets de conseil
interne vous nous dites quoi ça n'existe
pas non non c'est un cetain c'est un
abus de langage moi j'aime poser le
lendemain la question aux communicants
de gabriel attal ou le jour même fin je
me souviens plus en dix ans mais de quoi
vous parlez et en fait non pas de quoi
ils parlent
ça n'existe pas c'est à dire ouh ouh ça
existe déjà en fait il ya déjà une
direction interministérielle de la
transformation public qui était censée
être la boîte à outils de tous les
ministères résultat des courses 7d itp
la moitié de ses effectifs sont des
consultants en cdd qui passe montre
commandes de de contrat de consulting à
leur ancien employeur
donc c'est 16 l'exemple flagrant donc la
décision
s'est dit c'est toi c'est une réponse
assez une réponse à votre livre à la
commission en question face à elles ont
créé cette nation en fait ils vont créer
des référents des itp dans les mines
faire je vais vous dire moi ce qui me
frappe en termes de communication
ce sont on va le dire poliment les deux
me vérité les trois quarts
d'imprécisions de toute cette histoire
amélie dimanche à lundi publiquement
sous serment que les dépenses de
conseils n'ont pas dépassé 140 millions
d'euros et qu'elles ont été stables sous
le quinquennat macron la commission d'
enquête
démontre que ça a doublé et que ça a
dépassé le milliard d'euros seulement au
les mini savoir les gisements d'argent
les si je signe à la régie pandit s'est
pressée de 380 millions 2018 à 893 en
2021 pour les ministères sous ses traits
soit elle ne sait pas ce qui est
inquiétant soit elle n'a pas dit la
vérité ce qui n'est pas très bien que
chacun on demande à gabriel at-elle ce
qu'on va faire il dit on va créer un
cabinet de conseil un thème je demande
le jour même à son consultant une
demande en ce pas tout à fait sa demande
et amélie montjalin cet après midi vous
n'êtes pas allé au bout de la de la
citation d'emmanuel macron qui dit non
mais en fait c'est à cause de la crise
qui a eu un boom en 2021 ça va descendre
or de nouveaux je vous cite la
commission denquête ce matin prouve bien
que sur le total des dépenses 2021 ya 45
ans sur plus d'un milliard qui sont
consacrés à la crise et que
l'augmentation n'a rien du tout à voir
avec la crise qu'est ce que ça veut dire
et pourquoi je trouve ça très inquiétant
c'est que nous ce qu'on voulait faire
avec ce livre c'est une interpellation
démocratique stadia révélé un phénomène
et dire faisons débat ponton et que fait
le personnel politique il ne s'en saisit
pas d emmanuel macron et toute son
équipe de nous assumer parce qu'il n'y a
pas d'autres mamies a compris pour notre
à répondre alors
il nous reste moins de six minutes et il
ya quand même un élément je vois
vraiment qu'on en parle parce que c'est
l'un des éléments forts de de votre
conférence de presse de communication ce
matin qui concerne encore une fois le
cabinet américain mckinsey qui va devoir
rendre des comptes sur sa fiscalité deux
éléments d'abord cet extrait de
l'audition du directeur associé
responsable du secteur public chez
mckinsey france était le 18 janvier il
affirme ceci m'a quitté france est
enregistrée auprès du registre du
registre des sociétés l'ensemble des
contrats de travail est porté par cette
société de droit français et l'ensemble
deux chiffres du chiffre d'affaires est
porté par cette société de droit
français l'élément de vous mentionner
c'est que nous sommes organisés en forme
de succursales voilà rapportant à
l'entité mère qui est basé au delaware
mais l'ensemble de nos activités secteur
public secteur privé et l'ensemble des
contrats de travail sont portés par
cette société de droit français que ça
signifie que vous êtes soumis aux impôts
français comme n'importe quel sursis
n'était bien sûr monsieur le président
merci bien sûr il y a six pays dont
l'impôt sur les sociétés en france et
l'ensemble des salariés qui travaillent
dans une cité droit français qui paient
l'impôt en france
bien sûr monsieur le président karim
tadjeddine at il menti c'est ce que
voudrait bien savoir le présent la
commission enquête du sénat arnaud bazin
l'écoutent
nous ce qui nous a choqués c'est le fait
que monsieur tadjeddine nous disent en
audition nous payons impôt sur les
sociétés en france et que quand on
regarde sur les dix dernières années cet
impôt est à zéro et l'état zéro parce
que le bénéfice fiscal est
systématiquement n'égale le résultat
fiscal pardon est systématiquement
négatif voilà donc nous allons être en
référer au procureur de la république et
ce sera à lui d'apprécier la situation
alors double question il y en a ça sic à
ce qui va se passer maintenant justice
est saisie c'est ça le président de l'ad
s'est passé sous sa responsabilité le
président de la commission denquête va
lancer dégainer l'article 40 on
l'appelle et va saisir la justice
l'article 40 c'est une personnalité
notamment
pour aller à la connaissance de la
justice un fait délictueux tafer et donc
je bon je ne maîtrise pas très bien les
les mécanos mais moi je suis allé avec
le président bazin vérifier sur place et
effectivement c'est assez étonnant de
voir
000 00 quand on connaît le chiffre
d'affaires de makeen c est la question
en fait c'est tout un mécano qui est mis
en place avec les prix de transfert et
avec la maison mère donc destiné à la
maison mère qui est basé au delaware aux
états unis et chacun sait que le
delaware est un paradis fiscal mais on
nous dis attention certes il ne paye
peut-être pas d'impôts au delaware
puisque paradis fiscal mais il paye
l'état fait ils payent l'impôt à l'état
à l'état fédéral donc ils paient des
impôts au gouvernement des états unis
donc c'est tout c'est très complexée sa
part met en avant l'opacité donc pas moi
que quand on regarde les documents des
services fixes khouya 000 sébastien un
mot là dessus et vous pourrez conclure
bas de choses mais je trouve qu'il ya le
mensonge effectivement le mensonge a
fortiori devant le commission denquête
parlementaire ça doit être durement
sanctionnés parce que on vit dans un
système où il n'y a pas de principe de
responsabilité et le mauvais management
de l'action publique devient adjoint du
gouvernement 20 cas évoqués en creux il
vient aussi de ça il n'y a pas de
principe de responsabilité qui est
appliquée dans les fonctions publiques
ou très peu mais surtout deuxième chose
dire à la limite bon ils font
l'optimisation fiscale c'est légal je
parle pas du mensonge mais sont fiscales
en soit c'est légal en revanche la
question qu'on peut se poser derrière il
n'y a pas que l'effet que l'état
français finalement contribue plutôt
trésor public américain et aussi le fait
que quand vous êtes mckinsey c'est ce
que vous dites est ce qu'on peut
sérieusement imaginer qu'il n'y a jamais
de sujets de confidentialité de
renseignements économiques de
souveraineté est ce que sur la gestion
de la crise est ce que si vous êtes un
leader une agence internationale comme
ça vous conseillez telle ou telle
solution je sais pas d'hébergement
numérique est ce que vous croyez que
derrière mckinsey enfin peu importe
roland berg heures citron plusieurs
cabinets n'ont aucun lien avec peut-être
des industriels américains ou étrangers
qui eux auraient un intérêt à ce que
vous poussiez telle ou telle solution
parce que le problème des cabinets de
conseil c'est quand même celui là c'est
que les cabinets de conseil sont dans un
écosystème où ils vivent fin juillet où
il doit vivre aussi comment ils gagnent
de l'argent ils le gagnent aussi comme
ça quand vous poussez une solution
plutôt qu'une autre pas forcément parce
qu'il ya des pots de vin mais par le
même système de carrière carrière
exactement par le même système de
carrière et un jour vous promettez vous
mettez ça en avant et le lendemain vous
êtes mystérieusement recruté par
l'entreprise que vous avez il ya des
camions de conseils français un cap
gemini open sont des cabinets la station
qu'il faisait très intéressante c'est à
dire c'est la protection des données
c'est à dire que quand on confie des
missions un cabinet international
on ne sait pas et ça c'est vraiment un
gros problème et je pense que quand nous
déposerons notre proposition de loi on y
reviendra mais c'est qu'il n'y a pas là
pour le coup on parle et d'évaluation en
amont il n'y a pas d'évaluation en aval
il n'ya pas de suivi et les données où
sont les données qu'ils gardent des
données parce qu'on nous raconte ont
créé un logiciel dans pour un ministère
etc et puis après on s'en bat qui s'est
terminée on a fait la mission mais qui a
la clé qui a la clé veut aller temps
c'est pas les taxes et le cabinet et des
procédures qui sont prévus dans le monde
on est sympa sans faire
personne ne contrôle sur scène ils
contrôlent donc elle est le coup
malheureusement oui se débrouille
terminé merci beaucoup
un terran pourrait leur faire un c'était
vraiment passionnant aimerait faire dire
autre chose voyons encore beaucoup de
choses à dire les infiltrés c est le
titre de votre livre coécrit avec
matthieu aron et c'est donc publié aux
éditions alary merci encore d'avoir
participé à ce débat